para mantener operaciones seguras en el espacio.
A diferencia de las carreteras en la tierra,
en realidad no hay reglas de tráfico espacial.
Ninguna en absoluto, ¿de acuerdo?
Guau.
¿Qué podría salir mal con eso?
(Risas)
Ahora, lo realmente lindo
sería tener algo así como un mapa de tráfico espacial,
como un Waze para el espacio en el que se pudiera buscar
y ver cuáles son las condiciones actuales del tráfico en el espacio,
tal vez incluso predecirlas.
El problema con eso, sin embargo,
es que preguntan a cinco personas diferentes,
"¿Qué está pasando en órbita?
¿A dónde van las cosas?
y probablemente se obtienen diez respuestas diferentes.
¿Por qué es eso así?
Porque la información sobre cosas en órbita tampoco se comparte comúnmente.
¿Y si tuviéramos un sistema globalmente accesible,
un sistema de información de tráfico espacial abierto y transparente
que pudiera informar al público sobre dónde está ubicado todo
para tratar de mantener el espacio seguro y sostenible?
¿Y si el sistema pudiera ser usado
para formar normas de comportamiento basadas en evidencia...
estas reglas de tráfico espacial?
Así desarrollé ASTRIAGraph,
el primer sistema de monitoreo de tráfico espacial de crowdsourcing del mundo
en la Universidad de Texas en Austin.
ASTRIAGraph combina múltiples fuentes de información de todo el mundo:
gobierno, industria y academia,
y representa esto en un marco común al que cualquiera puede acceder hoy.
Aquí pueden ver 26 000 objetos que orbitan la tierra,
múltiples opiniones,
y se actualiza casi en tiempo real.
Pero volviendo a mi problema del mapa del tráfico espacial:
¿Qué pasa si solo tenía información del gobierno de EE. UU.?
Bueno, en ese caso, así sería su mapa de tráfico espacial.
¿Pero qué piensan los rusos?
Eso se ve significativamente diferente.
¿Quién tiene la razón? ¿Quién esta equivocado?
¿Qué debería creer yo?
¿En qué podría confiar yo?
Esto es parte del problema.
En ausencia de este marco para monitorear el comportamiento del actor espacial,
para monitorear la actividad en el espacio,
donde se encuentran estos objetos,
para conciliar estas inconsistencias
y hacer este conocimiento común,
en realidad corremos el riesgo de perder la capacidad
de usar el espacio para beneficio de la humanidad.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)(Vítores)